yeah but I don't see the Supreme Court
right now ciding against Trump on this
on this matter no it's not but it's
going to take like 3 years I say how
long will it drain resources that's it I
mean look they're doing it to every like
I've spent $500,000 in attorney's fees
on January 6 subpoenas special Council
subpoenas I'm just one of the guys I
mean this is what they want you to do
cop a plea bend the knee we'll give you
the book deal you know Cassidy
Hutchinson goes out in the world and lie
literally it's hilarious to me that her
most promising statement of Truth was
president Trump reaching through the
Beast and trying to grab the steer have
you been in the Beast I have there's
bulletproof window between the driver
and the car part of where president
Trump what did she was She Hulk did she
punch through the glass window and how
did she Trump right and how did she even
believe if someone told me that Donald
Trump got really green and big and then
I I have to believe it glass just gets
out of his way they're too scared of him
so he's the new Chuck Norris they'll
just